au moment en fait vous voulez les
événements se déroulent on est on est en
réunion c'est un séminaire qui se passe
tous les ans et en fait tout le gign est
rassemblée ainsi que des unités de
contreterrorisme de l'international la
date par un total hasard
complètement ce jour là et en fait
il ya eu un brouhaha en fait dans la
salle avec des téléphones qui ont
commencé à circuler des personnes qui
sont sorties avec le téléphone etc et on
a constaté en fait que l'attentât venait
d'avoir lieu au sein des locaux de
charlie hebdo et c'est vrai que c'est
fou parce que la date à laquelle
correspond dit justement je serai un
séminaire vous étiez tous réunis cc
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable c'est ça
c'est un truc peu de gens savaient et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose je
suis il ya pas très longtemps c'est vrai
que c'est un crime parce que vous étiez
tous ensemble pour un séminaire et ça
tombe ce jour là et c'est vrai qu'ils
ont vu voilà tout le monde sortir ils
ont commencé à sentir qu'il y avait un
truc importe comment comment ça se passe
à ce moment là comment comment et qu'est
ce qui se passe on vous dit quoi
on nous dit de temporiser en fait au
sein des opérationnels évidemment c'est
notre métier c'est notre coeur de métier
on s'entraîne pour ça on vit pour ça
donc on a envie de partir on a envie d'y
aller l'acheter tout ça en revanche les
individus sont pas localisés à ce moment
là donc le commandement nous met en
stand by dans la tente de d'éléments
concrets pour pouvoir entamer alors
nettement une traque comment ils sont
localisés alors qu'ils les localisent
ils sont localisés en fait le 8 au matin
parce qu'ils se rendent à une station
service où ils vont en fait récupérer
des vivres de l'eau etc avant de
reprendre la suite et à ce moment-là
l'alerté donnée avec une direction de
suite et donc un secteur un secteur
délimité qui permet tout de suite de
mettre en place tout le dispositif des
forces de l'ordre qui a été mis en place
pendant cette période et je souhaite
encore
souligné en fait cet engagement de tous
de toutes les forces de l'ordre que ce
soit policiers gendarmes militaires
pompiers qui ont qui ont le vrai en fait
pour la chaire traque parce que ça a
permis de mettre une pression en fait
sur sur les terroristes qui les intérêts
pendant un moment avant qu'il ne
ressorte concrètement dubois
le 9 au matin alors quand on est on est
aussi l'hygiène on se dit qu'on se dit
j'ai envie d'aller intervenir où j'ai
envie j'ai pas envie de faire partie de
ceux qui vont intervenir c'est ça non
mais c'est important c'est vrai alors
déjà je vais pas si c'est une chose
parce que l'on a
je ne suis plus originaux jour de
l'accord je suis toujours en activité sa
mère à une suis plus au sein d'un camp
viennent aujourd'hui d'accord d'accord
travers six bien pour le très bien
serhan pas d'accord
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous vous engagez
pour sauver des vies donc à partir du
moment où vous vous disiez romain vous
disiez j'espère que je vais pouvoir la
terminer sur la wii et je ne pense pas
que vous puissiez trouver un seul membre
du groupe qui à ce moment-là 10 ben moi
j'ai piscine où je mène me faire à quoi
poney c'est sûr ça tout le monde tout le
monde veut y aller quand on vous demande
d'y aller que si vous vous dites dans
votre tête enfin c'est vrai enfin oui
vous vous engagez pour des valeurs vous
vous engagez pour défendre les gens vous
engager pour le peuple et à ce moment là
vous vous vous entraînez en permanence
vous fait des sacrifices sur votre vie
de famille vous fait des sacrifices sur
votre carrière parce qu'en fait rentrer
au gign bloc un petit peu votre votre
parcours de carrière notre avancement et
c est là à ce moment là vous dites je
m'entraîne pour ça parce que c'est vrai
que vive pour ça il faut le dire un le
gign s'est énormément d'entraînement
pour des interventions vraiment qu'ils
sont très rares c'est vrai donc on
s'entraîne on s'entraîne mais c'est pas
voilà on interviendra tous les jours on
époux on s'entraîne pour des
interventions de ce genre aussi voilà
dans notre coeur de métier c'est le
contre terrorisme à lacets s'arrangeant
ville aux ponts le groupe fait beaucoup
d'un bien sûr sur l'essentiel devrait le
grand banditisme bien sûr il ya beaucoup
d'emplois mes mails et leurs jouets
thiessard vie pour pour le contrecarrer
ce qu'on sait quelle sera leur aide qui
fait partie de la police c'est ça le
ministère l'intérieur et il ya le gign
s'est lassé la gendarmerie c'est là le
voilà et donc c'est vrai qu'au vous
entraînez vous entraîner là on vous dit
on vous dit que vous allez intervenir
vous savez que les frères cauchy on l'a
vu ils sont ils sont prêts à tout est ce
que vous appelez votre famille avant
vous leur dites voilà je vais intervenir
sur une opération sur cette opération le
premier réflexe que j'ai au moment où
ou par concrètement en convoi c'est
d'appeler mon épouse mais je lui demandé
d'éteindre la télé d'accord avec ça a
toujours été convenu avec elle que le
jour où ça arrivait où je partais sur
une grosse intervention qui forcément à
lettres très médiatisées
quel break au niveau des médias c'est
terrible et je lui ai demandé de sortir
des jeux de s'isoler entre guillemets
des différents textes auxquels pouvaient
recevoir avait des enfants oui deux
d'accord ils sont quel âge c'était déjà
elle avait 15 ans et 5 6 ans à cordes on
confond les enfants aussi je veux pas
qu'ils extinction de la télé pas de
radio et ça doit être terrible pour être
la seule à lui est dans un stress
terrible non plus elle sait où elle vous
écoute et de la fée ou bien là oui bien
sûr elle l'a fait à la va craquer il n'a
pas à elle connaît la nuisance que
peuvent avoir les médias d'accord et je
pense que c'est justement sur ces
interventions là une chaîne
d'information
continue mais il continue toujours
d'ailleurs dans la même ça vous savez ça
portait préjudice les informations
qu'ont donné les journalistes pendant ce
tout à fait je crois même qu'il ya des
plaintes construire déposée pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui mais quand
donc trouve que alors vous êtes percuté
par cas combien là bas c'est quoi le à
ce moment là il ya quasiment les trois
quarts de l'effectif du gign qui sont
engagés sur la traque le 8 d'accord avec
un secteur délimité qui est
qui est qui partager en deux avec leur
aide et une partie
une partie du gpn d'accord de lille il
me semble et en fait on a on a des zones
bien des libyens défini à ratisser mais
vraiment à proprement tard ça représente
combien de mode saas et les trois-quarts
de les effectuer trois quarts de
l'effectif à ce moment là on était
quasiment un peu plus de 100
opérationnelles d'accord entre 100 et
120 opérationnel
les autres qui étaient en dise postage
permission etc ont été bipé également je
l'assumé comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure ils n'ont pas demandé leur reste
ils sont revenues d'initiative et dans
la nuit en fête du 8 au 9
il y a eu
il ya eu 1 1 une bascule de force on
appelle ça qui a été programmé par le
commandement c'est à dire relever les
personnels qui visent qu il y avait déjà
fait 24 heures sur le terrain pour pour
qui ce reconditionne et pouvoir
continuer avec avec le reliquat de
personnel qui arrive alors quand vous
arrivez vous étiez à l'imprimerie
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe là
comment ça se passe alors dans un
premier temps
lorsqu'on arrive
on est il ya un mauvais aiguillage avec
un petit une petite encore isation dans
la communication entre les éléments de
gendarmerie départementale qui sont sur
place et nous premier élément qui
arrivant sur les lieux on nous indique
forcément étant donné la dangerosité des
individus il avait été demandé de faire
un bouclage large donc les gendarmes
départementaux présent nous indique que
connaissent le terrain mais nous non et
nous indique le hangar ou à gauche le
hangar au bout à gauche était en fait un
entrepôt de
d'un grand groupe de distribution donc
ce n'était pas le bon endroit on
commence à partir de su très rapidement
les hélicoptères arriver comment cela
héros cordages avec avec les autres
équipes et rapidement on a l'info que
c'est pas là mais c'est juste à côté
donc réarticulation très rapide et on se
dirige sur l'imprimerie à ce moment là
il ya une véhicule qui était du même
modèle et de la même couleur que le
véhicule signalé des individus qui se
présentent au bout de la rue
incroyable petit ascenseur émotionnel
avec me ou là en fait on se dit ça y est
c'est le moment
mais clairement c'était une solution de
facilité pour nous car si les individus
se présenter là c'était terminé voilà la
puissance dès lors qu'elle est donc là
c'était qui c'était quelqu'un qui avait
c'était je pense quelqu'un qui sortait
du travail
mais ça c'est une vraie info je pense
qu'il peut amener une petite marche
arrière toute
c est incroyable on écoute le hasard
enfin mme bédard alors ensuite vous à
vous allez ça va être bientôt l'assaut
vous savez qu'il ya un carottage
les frères kwasi vont commencer à sortir
commencé à tirer vous êtes tous voient
ce moment là au moment en fait où ils
sortent d'eux
de l'imprimerie moi j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir occuper plusieurs postes en fait
sur le sur la préparation de l'assaut et
sur l'assaut et après avoir pris un
poste d'appui sur sur
le hangar qui situé en face de
l'imprimerie sur descendus du toit pour
rejoindre les colonnes mon chef de
groupe avait déjà prévu un bouclier
alors que j'ai habituellement mater
bouclier parce que vous étiez bouclier
normalement habituellement
habituellement sur l'émission oui alors
on va expliquer aux téléspectateurs ce
qui sait que le bouclier c'est plus et
on en sait beaucoup qui est ton
programme appelle le paratonnerre en
fait vous savez que vous allez prendre
la foudre voilà et
le but en fait c'est justement d'attirer
la foudre pour que ça soit pas vos
camarades qu'ils apprennent et que les
ça soit du grand banditisme ou du
terrorisme que le terroriste
focalise vous les feux sur vous qui êtes
protégé au pouvoir alors c'est toujours
pareil dans la protection balistique et
une certaine limite il ya toujours des
droits qui sont là mais
on accepte on accepte ce facteur et on
se sent c'est qu'on va essayer de tout
concentrer sur nous pour que le travail
soit fait pour la neutralisation des
individus incroyable c'est donc ce soir
là nous avons là vous n'étiez pas bouclé
donc étant donné que j'étais parti
prendre un appui sur le toit en face la
manie la balle à l'équipe constituée
pour être bouclier avec prévu sans moi
parce que tout à fait normale et je suis
réarticuler avec l'équipe de manu et on
en fait on au moment où on va se mettre
en place on a le fait une brèche dans un
dans un grillage qui est sur le côté de
l'imprimerie et au moment où on arrive à
la brèche pour puisqu'on avait comme
mission de pénétrer par
la façade opposée
dont la façade qu'il est à droite de la
porte d'entrée quand vous êtes face à
l'imprimerie des charges explosives a
été placé et notre but était donc notre
mission pour nous était de pénétrer par
ces brèches là
et au moment où on arrive donc à la
brèche du grillage pour traverser à
l'est derrière on entend à la radio
l'annnonce de comme quoi la porte
s'entrouvre donc là forcément il ya une
temporisation qui doit qu'il va durer
environ une trentaine ou une quarantaine
de secondes ce qui dansait dans ces
moments là paraît une éternité mais on
est bien conscient que notre mission
avait pas de rester là donc au moment où
fait ou on se on se remet en mouvement
c'est à ce moment là qu'ils sortent et
qui commence à ouvrir le feu sur tous
les personnels qui sont devant l'entrée
et qui sont directement à droite en
sortant de l'imprimerie donc moi je me
trouvais à peu près une vingtaine de
mètres des individus
et là en fait c'est un déluge de feu qui
commence avec tout ce qui est à
rattacher vous voyez voyez les feuilles
qu'il est les eps qui commence à se
faire tondre l'a repris à côté j'ai un
camarade qui s'est caché qui se fait
tout petit avec les corses qui ramasse
et là en fait vous êtes en partie happé
par l'action parce que c'est votre bien
sûr c'est votre but c'est les arrêter le
but il était de 2-2 le vraiment les
engagées portent fictif plus qu'il ne
fuie et ensuite de les interpeller quoi
ça a duré combien de temps le échange de
coups de feu après un échange de coups
de feu ça a été assez rapide il me
semble c'est vrai
environ une dizaine de secondes il ya
deux phases de feu en fait la première
justement au moment où on se remet en
mouvement et là ils sortent
très rapidement il ya une partie de ma
colonne qui s'engagent en renfort sur
sur les individus
après technique du spaghetti tuyaux on
appelle ça c'est quoi c'est à dire que
ben si vous prenez un spaghetti cuit
vous le mettez sur un plan de travail
mouillez vous le fait de faire le
serpent arrive à suivre et donc si les
premiers s'engage dans une voie des
grandes chances que l' le spaghetti
suivent donc la colonne risquer de
suivre et la lucidité de tous les
intervenants dans une colonne c'est
d'avoir la capacité de réaction en se
disant ok certes mon chef est devant
c'est lui qui commande la manip il est
parti devant pour porter main forte à
mes camarades mais on a le devoir
d'aller remplir la mission qui va si
nous est attribuée de l'autre et à ce
moment je jette un coup d'oeil je vois
tous mes camarades qui vont suivre parce
qu'on veut tous aller au feu et on part
rapidement se placer à notre base
d'assaut de l'autre côté parce que sur
le briefing il était clairement établie
qu'à partir du moment où les frères
coach y mettait les pieds à l'extérieur
de l'imprimerie ont déclenché ce qu'on
appelle le plan d'action d'urgence
qui est un plan en fait qui vise qui
visait à ce moment là à pouvoir
interdire complètement le retour des
terroristes à l'intérieur de
l'imprimerie parce qu'il restait un
otage battue n'était pas identifié ou re
à l'intérieur mais au moins en cas de
piégeage à l'intérieur etc l'explosif
faisait son travail de des piégeages et
on pouvait pénétrer en sécurité relative
et les empêcher de rentrer à l'intérieur
pour préserver la vie de l'otage vous
auriez aimé les attraper vivent bien sûr
c'était l'objectif c'était l'objectif
mais c'est impossible
c'était c'était très très compliqué
ferrari c'était très compliqué étant
donné que les individus à ce moment là
il était établi qu'ils avaient
différents réseaux en parallèle avec eux
oui mais il y avait des forces forts
soupçons de piégeage bien sûr et à ce
moment là
déjà eu on savait qu'ils étaient
porteurs de grenades de gillet on savait
pas si c'était des gilles et explose au
delà des gilets pare-balles
et 6 7 6 il était arrivé dans
l'imprimerie avec un renfort peut-être
dans l'imprimerie qui auraient déposé
des choses et c'était on ne savait pas
et ça donc donc vous établissez si vous
voulez une distance de sécurité que vous
considérez comme tolérable tolérable
jusqu'au moment où les individus sont
trop proches et là vous n'avez plus de
choix sur le départ vous faites du tir
de neutralisation aux membres c'est ce
qui s'est passé la première partie de
feu a été sur les membres avec des
individus qui étant donné leur
antériorité numérique sauter dans tous
les sens si on arrive à un moment qu'ils
étaient sous drogue etc les autopsies
ont révélé la verse
on les a vu sauter dans tous les sens
pour rendre plus compliquée le tir de
cibles mobiles
il ya même un moment où chérif kouachi
est tombé à poser un genou il s'est fait
touché au bras il a changé larmes de
côté pour reprendre le feu et continuer
à avancer sur sur les camarades jusqu'au
moment où là la distance dont je vous
parlais devient trop proches et on sait
que si là il se fait claquer ils
risquent de d'emmener d'amener des
camarades ericsson il faut hélas ils
font aucun effort effectué un tir de
neutralisation par un tir à tu sais ça
mais il t'a sont ils savaient bien
qu'ils n'avaient aucune chance à quai il
peut pas s'en sortir donc forcément il
voit là mais on reste persuadé qu'à ce
moment là ils sont pas conscients de la
puissance dans les rues qui à
l'extérieur et c'est ça d'accord